I would include LeBron James as part of
the machine LeBron James who in some
ways has almost single-handedly
destroyed the NBA because people have
had it with the politics and he accuses
everyone being racist all the time he
has no bad words ever to say about China
uh he had a tweet about the Twitter
situation
he said I don't know Elon Musk and to be
honest I could care less who owns
Twitter but I will say that if this is
true I hope his people take this very
seriously because this is scary as [ __ ]
you can or AF so many damn unfit people
saying hate speech is Free Speech this
was a retweet of this guy Philip Lewis
who said Elon musk's Twitter takeover
Sparta surge in the use of the n-word on
the social media platform a social media
research group told the Washington Post
the use of the slur increased by nearly
500 percent blah blah blah okay so
what's interesting here first off LeBron
if you're watching there is no such
thing as hate speech the Supreme Court
has decided on this what we have is free
speech and then outside of free speech
and the very very specific limitations
around free speech meaning that you
can't uh directly threaten somebody's
life something like that you can't walk
into a theater and yell fire with the
intent to do harm that's the specific
caveat around that and then we have very
very tight laws as you guys know related
to libel and slander when it's spoken
and written uh but beyond that there's
no such thing as hate speech because one
person's hate speeches another person's
Free Speech LeBron is very upset that
suddenly because Free Speech will be
defended more on Twitter and they're not
going to stop hate speech which again is
an indefinable term uh Lebron is very
upset well it's not like LeBron would
have spread fake stories over the years
and whipped up some odd racism himself
would it
here's NBC a couple years ago LeBron
James explained his decision late
Wednesday to delete a tweet about the
Fatal police shooting of 16 year old
Micaiah Bryant in Columbus Ohio the Los
Angeles Lakers star tweeted a photo
Wednesday afternoon that appeared to
show the officer who was involved in the
shooting of Bryant with the caption I'm
so damn tired of seeing black people
killed by police I took the Tweet down
because it's being used to create more
hate this isn't about one officer it's
about the entire system and they will
always use our words to create more
racism I am so desperate for more
accountability
backlash with Swift with Senator Tom
Cotton accusing the NBA champion of
inciting violence against a police
officer this is disgraceful and
dangerous he tweeted is the NBA okay
with this is Twitter the body worn
camera of police officer Nick Reardon
recorded how he arrived at a reported
disturbance late Tuesday afternoon
Reardon drew his weapon as the
altercation unfolded the video show code
police have said the video shows someone
trying to stab a person on the ground as
well as a second person so you may
remember this story and I'm only showing
this that everyone has these odd moments
where they suddenly care about truth
even though they've been exposed
to be lying about things over time you
may remember that story where the
officer arrived as this woman with a
Cleaver was about to stab the hell out
of another woman and he shot the woman
with the knife he didn't oh could you
just put down the nut you guys got it
you guys got it the officer actually
saved a black woman's life everyone
should know the officer's name for
saving a black woman's life but when
LeBron thought he could blame that on
the police and he's so damn tired of all
of it well then he was willing to do
that but LeBron he's in over his head